ترقد الام في حاله حرجه بقسم العنايه
المشدده ويتوزع اطفالها في اقسام المستشفى
حسب درجه الحروق
والحريق ناتج عن تسرب الغاز واشتعال
النيران في المنزل وهذا حال المنزل دون ان
تنفجر الاسطوانه فقط هو ضغط الغاز ادى الى
خلع النوافذ والابواب وحتى سطح المنزل
البسيط
متسببا بمعاناه كبيره لواحده من الاسر
النازحه بمارب تسرب غاز
وجيت الزوجه الصباح تشتي تولع في المطبخ
فحدث انفجار مفاجئ انفجار حتى اقترع السطح
حق البيت واشتعل البيت كلنا الاولاد كانوا
في الغرفه المجاور للمطبخ وكلهم كلهم
علقوا تتحدث تقارير صحفيه عن 12 مليون
اسطوانه غاز تالفه في اليمن ضحاياها كل
يوم العشرات من النساء والاطفال اعداد
تزايدت خلال سنوات الحرب مع توقف الصيانه
كميات كبيره من الاسطوانات غير الامنه الى
السوق المحليه زرنا منشاه الغاز في مارب
وفي منصه التعبئه يتم تحريز اسطوانات
الغاز التالفه وغير الامنه والتي بلغت 24
الفا نعمل الجاهدين على تحريز الاسطوانات
التالفه ولدينا مخزون لا يقارب 24 الف سوف
تطلعون عليه من الاسوان التالفه لا يمكن
ان تخرج اسطوانه من المنشاه وهي تالفه اذا
في اسطوانه تالفه نحرزها في المنصه تتحدث
الجهات المعنيه عن اهمال مشترك في التعامل
مع اسطوانات الغاز ما يؤدي لزياده حالات
الانفجار وعن حلول للصيانه بدات بالشراكه
مع الجانب السعودي وتدريب الكوادر
لاصلاحها قاده الشركه عملت في الفتره
الاخيره على استخدام 100 الف صمام يعني
نوعيه جيده والان في الميناء في عدن معانا
60 الف اسطوانه جديد في مصنع الرياض
واصلها في الطريق والاجراءات تمشيه تباعنا
ان شاء الله هو مطمئن المواطنين بانه ان
شاء الله قد تحدث احداث يعني نادره ونادر
لا حكم لها الى قنابل موقوته تتحول
اسطوانات الغاز في منازل اليمنيين ومئاسي
الحرائق كثيره في كل المحافظات محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب